هذا هو أول يوم لي أعتقد أنني أرغب
في الاستفادة من وجود
الكثير من زملائي اليوم
وفي اليومين المقبلين سأكون قادرًا
على الحصول على رؤية أكثر تركيزًا بكثير
حتى أنه يوجد أيضًا العديد من
الممثلين  الصناعة هنا
يمكن للمرء أيضًا الاستفادة من حاضرهم
للتحدث معهم حول السوق حيث يمكنني أن
أفعل شيئًا ما ، هل
سيكون هناك خروج حاد عن
السياسة الحالية وهذا ما
يريد الجميع معرفته بعد مثل هذه الخطوة الجذرية
مع الوزير  علي الذي تعرفه
جيدًا لا يوجد شيء جذري في المملكة
العربية السعودية ، نحن جميعًا موظفون مدنيون
نعمل لحساب الحكومة ونفضل واجباتنا
ويأتي شخص واحد ويذهب شخص واحد
وفي نهاية اليوم نخدم
قضيتنا وهدفنا  القلق الواضح
والحاضر هو ما إذا كنت
ستغير تحالف أوبك غير الأعضاء في منظمة البلدان المصدرة للبترول (أوبك) وترى أن
هناك حاجة إلى تخفيضات أعمق بسبب التباطؤ العالمي
كما قلت سابقًا أنا هنا
لست مستمعًا جيدًا كما تعرفني لذلك
أود استخدام  وتجعلك تعرف استخدام
المنفعة أو الاستفادة من وجود
زملائي ، تحدث معهم ثم قم
بصياغة رأيي بناءً على ما
أسمعه من مجموعة حتى لا تغيرات مفاجئة
ما تقترحه هناك ، لقد
عملنا دائمًا من أجل
سلطة جماعية متماسكة  داخل
أوبك وخارجها كما تعلم ، لقد أمضينا
الكثير من الوقت مع نفسي أو مع العديد
من الوزراء الذين سبقوني في
التأكد من أن المنتجين
يجتمعون معًا
ويزدهرون معًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً
لمنظمة أوبك  تحالف
أوبك على الرغم من أنه مع غير الأوبك ، فأنت لا
تتخلى عن ذلك مع رياح
الجميع ، نعم ، سوف يفعل ذلك
[موسيقى]